Hey everybody.
What the fuck is going on.
This is one of the very last versions
of the Joe Rogan questions everything
podcasts that we're releasing
as an actual podcast.
We did somewhere around 10 of
them and I think we have two left.
So probably this one and one other one
might not have been 10 but don't get all
specific.
Ladies and gentlemen this show
was really a pleasure to do the.
The big pleasure of it was working with
my buddy Duncan of course and exposing
him to millions of people worldwide who
didn't didn't know about my brilliant
friend and one of things I really love
about doing podcast with Duncan is he
really gets me inspired to go on these
wild rants and I think I inspire him in
the same way and we have this really cool
give and take energy when it comes to
certain things and he was just
absolutely brilliant on the show and in
introducing subjects and talking to
people and injecting new ideas into these
silly subjects like psychics which is
this this episode and a huge thank you to
Benishek who was the guy who
we interviewed during the
show and had him put on a
little bit of a demonstration that really
opened up my mind to what is possible
in the world of trickery and manipulation
and sleight of hand the art thereof of
it.
I mean I'd always known that there was
a real art to magic but boy did that guy
blow my mind.
And what are the things I
really appreciated about
battered check was that he
blew my mind and then he
told me it was all bullshit.
He didn't try to pretend that he had
some magic power or some device that only
the government knows about
hidden horseshit you.
He told you after he was doing that.
And even during the time he was doing it
that it was all bullshit but he was so
good at it it was still
unbelievably fascinating.
I hope this also opens up a
lot of people's eyes as to
what is possible in terms
of trickery in terms of what someone
can what someone can trick you into
believing and what kind of manipulation
people can pull off when they pretend to
have psychic abilities.
There's a lot of that going on folks.
There's I mean there very well may be
some sort of a psychic energy that people
possess whether it's a sense that people
are not aware of or smells that people
can detect that they can't quite describe
that aren't quite olfactory but to
some sense of something being wrong.
But there's also a lot
of liars out there man.
There's a lot of fakers and
there's a lot of bullshit.
And one of the things that I was most
proud about the sci fi show was that we
were able to expose some of that bullshit
and whether it was bullshit about the
science behind chem trails or whether
it was the evidence in quotes when it
comes to UFOs or whether it was not
bullshit like the that the technical and
technological innovation that's going
on at this incredibly rapid rate that
we're experiencing and where
this all could lead to.
You know it was one of my favorite
parts about the show in fact.
One of the least controversial
and most real aspects of the show.
But ultimately it was a lot of fun to do.
And so thank you to Duncan Trussell
and Duncan has an amazing podcast that
Duncan Trussell family hour.
He's an amazing standup comedian.
He's just one of my favorite
human beings on the planet.
He and Chris Ryan who is the author of
Sex at Dawn and me are doing a joint
podcast once a month.
We just did Duncans really recently that
Duncan Trussell family our and we doing
Chris Ryan's podcast podcast
which is tangentially speaking.
And then I will do mine again and we'll
just keep rotating once a month we'll do
each other.
But just awesome to have
those guys as friends.
Awesome to be able to do this show with
Duncan and awesome to be able to work
with such awesome guys like Tom Mesereau
who is the executive producer and and
Frank and Michael from Arthur Smith and
just we had a great time and all the
people at Sci fi Tim and Wayne
and everyone thank you very much.
We really really enjoyed working with
you guys and I really appreciate the
opportunity and I really appreciate you
letting me release these podcasts that
we recorded on the show.
A lot of people thought they were
like we were faking podcasts they were
actually real podcasts and allegedly
there was real marijuana involved.
Anyway this is one of the last ones and
this one is brought to you by Ting Ting
is a cell phone service that
utilizes the sprint backbone.
It's one of my favorite all time podcast
sponsors because I have had nothing but
positive feedback from Ting Ting is the
cell phone service if you've heard us
talk about it before that uses Top End
and phones and what they do is they rent
space off of the off the sprint backbone
so they do it on their terms like they
don't have any contracts they don't have
any early termination fees they don't
have all the nonsense that a lot of
people have that's attached to his cell
phone service it's like hidden fees and
overages with Tang you only pay for what
you use if you go over your allotted
minutes you just pay for what you use is
not some exorbitant rate that you have
to pay for it's not some some go fuck
yourself nonsense that comes along because
that's that's a real problem with a
lot of these companies that are selling
cell phone services that they're greedy
they don't just want a little bit they
want it all they want to suck you dry and
get out of you whatever they can get out
of you What team does is they sell you
the very best of all of the Android phones
like the Samsung Galaxy Note 3 which
is what I use or they use the the Galaxy
S4 which is another suite phone the HTC
One there's a bunch of these really bad
ass Android phones and they do it in a
way where you are going to save money
guaranteed you're going to save it because
98 percent of people 98 percent people
would save money would tank if you're one
of those 2 percent MAN YOU NEED TO LOOK
AT YOURSELF WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU DUDE
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU MAN.
Why are you saving money.
Hmm hmm hmm hmm.
Are you a crazy with
how you use your phone.
What's wrong man.
What is wrong with you.
Most people save.
I know Chris Ryan uses it.
He saves.
I know.
It's just it's all in all a
better way to do business.
And again no contracts.
If you want to leave you just leave.
You have to deal with
any fucking nonsense.
You don't have to deal with any of the
bullshit that you deal with a regular
cell phone networks.
And again you use really
awesome cell phones.
So
what is that.
You are hell.
I can't find it.
I got updated copied.
They want me to say some
things not broken is it.
You know why do I feel
like it's different.
I just wanna make sure it's okay.
Hold on folks.
This is not much of an advertising here.
Rogan Dr. income
is that it.
Yes.
Okay.
Go to Rogan debt to income and you'll
save twenty five dollars off any of their
new Android phones a device.
I couldn't recommend them enough.
They're an ethical company and they're a
company that's trying to do what I wish
all companies would do.
What I wish all companies would do was
try to make money but don't try to make
all the fucking money.
I mean isn't it possible that you can
you know make a little bit less money and
not have people fucking pissed off at you.
So go to Rogan DOT team dot com
and enjoy their mobile company.
That makes sense.
It's a no bullshit mobile service.
They say B.S.
and a copy I say bullshit OK.
You can call them their customer support
at 1 8 5 5 10 FTE w they use internet
speak like ting for the win.
Don't you love that.
And they have online support
and helped out tame dot.com.
So go to Rogan dotting dot com.
Save yourself some cash.
Ash were also brought to you by hove or
hove or is it's actually hover hover as
a domain name company that I use myself.
Hover hover while I call it
hover I'm fucking asshole.
That's why I've been using
hover for over a year now.
I've registered several domains with
Hover it's super easy to do and hover has
it set up where you get things for free
like who is domain name services hover
is actually owned by the same people
that own tanks so the same ethics sort of
applies to hover that applies to tank
trying to give you a good service at a
reasonable rate where you could feel good
about the transaction and that really
should be what business is all about
they should give you something where you
pay for it what you feel like it's worth
and then you get the bill at the end of
the month.
Oh well that was worth that
and that that's possible.
OK it can be like that and you don't
get that with early termination fees and
all that shit.
They're taking advantage of you.
Fucking man hover gives you exactly what
you need to get the job done you find
the perfect domain name for your idea
to live so you can get started on it and
move on to the next
thing on your to do list.
Know why they even have a copy.
Don't tell me what to do.
I know about my to do list you fucks but
if you're looking for the great place
the best place for a domain
geeks developers designers
and programs are always
talking about hover and
even people like me.
I guess somebody's a geek very uneducated
geek but Harvard gives you easy to use
powerful tools tools to manage your
domain and they also make it very easy to
import your domain over to hover.
They they actually called a valet transfer
the people that hover are experts at
domain so you don't have to be.
They just want to take all the friction
out of managing your domains and they
want you to be able to
manage them all in one place.
So they offer you a valet transfer
service to make it as easy as possible to
move your domains hover.
Also also offers Google Apps for Your
domains which is pretty sweet to have on
you can just set it up from hover.
Really easy to do.
Super intuitive interface and hover has
outstanding customer support because
Google is a huge company and pretty much
impossible to get a hold of if you ever
need a hand.
They can do it through hover they can
help you with your Google Apps and you can
try 30 days of Google apps on your domain
for free at hover to see if you'd like
it
so these days Ladies Gentlemen it makes
sense to get your own unique email
address and they can do
that and hover as well.
Personal professional and cooler
than your Hotmail or your AOL.
You still have AOL.
You're a fool.
You're not going to
fucking get my business.
Contact me.
Johnny shit pants at AOL dot com.
Works at AOL what.
So you never have to switch e-mails and
send one of those Hey everyone I got a
new email to everyone on your contact
lists that you hate that shit.
And an email from hover is
one that you'll won't outgrow.
It's easy to remember.
It's portable.
You can switch away from
your email provider without
losing your email address.
So go to her over.
Ladies and gentlemen hover dot com
and you can use the code word Bigfoot.
This for this episode it's Bigfoot.
Use the code word Bigfoot
and save yourself some cash.
Why Bigfoot.
Well because we're trying to look see
like how many people pay attention to
which episode and which
one is more effective.
So to save some money the promo code for
this episode is Bigfoot use it and go
fuck yourself.
Don't go fuck yourself I don't really
mean that I say that shit but I'm just
trying to be silly.
I'm just trying to give you a little
levity before you delve into the world of
fake psychics.
So with that without any further ado
thank you very much for tuning into the
podcast.
Thank you very much for all the love
online and Twitter and so many people that
I've met that tell me they appreciate
the podcast and I appreciate the fuck out
of you guys as well.
And if not for all the information that
a lot of you tweet to me and send me on
Facebook and things people tell me about
when I meet them I mean we are in a
very strange time ladies and gentlemen
and we are sharing information and I am
merely a conduit to do to distribute
some of that information your way.
And I'm honored and I'm out of here.
So enjoy the podcast and because
it's will gain experience by.
So this podcast is about psychics
and maybe the lack thereof.
You know at a certain
point time in the show.
You got it.
I was wondering what exactly was
going on when it came to psychics.
I always wondered.
I mean I would never want to completely
discredit the possibility that someone
could have some extraordinary
power that I don't possess.
Who knows.
You know I mean in a
way it's been explained.
McKenna described communication as a form
of telepathy talking because in a way
you're you're making established sounds
with your mouth that are attached to a
cultural context that
we all sort of agree to.
And in doing so you're reading my mind.
I'm talking to you.
You know what I'm I'm
talking about a laptop.
I went to the store to get my laptop fixed
and the guy behind the counter was in
such a nice guy.
You were you're experiencing that with
me you know so you're sort of like
getting a version of my memories.
And so I never wanted to like
completely say oh it's all b.s.
there's no way but man as we do the show
like The more we did it at a certain
point Tom I was like how much of this is
fucking free you know how much of this
is kooky.
There was there were several times
we were doing the show where else.
Like Paul Smith who seemed like a very
nice guy tried to get me to a remote view
and I had nothing screw a bunch of stuff
down on paper and he was like Just go
to with whatever is moving you know
just like there's nothing there.
I honestly maybe it's just me.
I mean I left it to me.
I'm like I want to see him do it because
you know he'd been doing it for more
than a decade.
He's an expert at and he's actually had
positive results with it but me trying
it.
They were saying that they could show me
how to do it within X amount of minutes
I would be doing it right.
Nothing I wrote.
I drew some stuff that I drew like a
square and I wrote the color red and
something was square with red in it but
it was I guess it was a dumb guess it
was a guest where there was a bunch
of shapes and stuff in this location.
So if I had to judge myself on a pass or
fail I would give myself a ninety nine
point nine nine percent fail.
I can't say 100 percent fail because I
did have a square that had red in it and
there was something like that.
It seems to me to be like
something that shows up a lot.
Look there's this hour on air sign
it's a rectangle that has red in it.
I mean it's like there's a lot
of squares with red and I'm Yeah.
So I think that easily
could have been nonsense.
So but then I talked to Ed dames
okay and he's the number one top dog.
If you start Google and like
people that are able to do that.
People that have that remote viewing
skill Ed dames name comes up like
immediately.
He's like the godfather of this stuff.
He started that Stargate program.
You know so he was
working on remote viewing.
He said they had really positive result.
He said he knows how to do it.
And he said that they found Osama bin
Laden and he actually said they found
Osama bin Laden.
He believes they didn't go
after him because they didn't
want to end the war yet
for whatever reason you know.
So take that for you know
the grain of salt whatever.
Maybe he's right.
But now you do take something like that
with a grain of salt like he's saying
that psychics saw Osama bin Laden
who did they call go how does that
conversation go down.
Hey what's that.
Well he's not to psychics
he's working for the CIA.
He's in the government.
He's working in the government right.
I mean he's he's been.
And he said also in this I found this
kind of interesting and kind of make
sense.
He said that they were trying to like
distance themselves from this program
because it's like this paranormal thing
like you're working on like psychics.
And he was like even if it was effective
they were like look we don't want to be
connected to that because it just
sounds too loony even if it's effective.
Well you know what man.
If you look at the history of the
various experiments the CIA have done.
They're not afraid of loony right they
were dumping acid into a guy's mouth and
brothels with to a windows.
You see the effects of LSD.
Once you've done that you'll do anything
for folks who don't know that story.
It was called the
operation midnight climax.
And what they did was they they
bought brothels in New York and in San
Francisco.
And these guys they came in to engage
in you know prostitution type activities
and they dosed them.
They dosed them with LSD.
Yeah.
And it's an amazing story because the
guys can say shit you know you're not
supposed to be in a whorehouse anyway
and you're out there and you're getting
dosed up with acid like Yikes Holy shit.
They did a lot more than that man.
A lot more than that they
went in a mental asylum.
And they doped people up so much that
they tried to rewrite their memories to
fix their their various mental disorders.
They wanted to see if they
could or right erase memories.
They're doing this to mentally
ill people in mental hospitals.
I'll look it up.
Project Monarch.
The whole point is the CIA is not afraid
of putting their feet and crazy river.
They do it all the time.
So I think that the idea that they there
is they stopped this thing because they
don't want to embarrass themselves.
No they stopped it because it wasn't
working because let me tell you.
Okay but let's let's for a moment before
I stop you I just want to play devil's
advocate okay.
All of those things that we're
mentioning are in the past.
Operation midnight climax
believes in the 1950s.
Yeah the this remote viewing movement.
They stopped.
That is well.
Is it possible and again this is just
devil's advocate that they try things and
they don't work so they move on.
Is that possible.
Is it possible that they it's
it's just that it didn't work.
I mean I think that if any government
on the planet figured out a way to use a
team of elite psychics to
locate their enemies right.
They're not gonna be like oh let's cancel
this program it's embarrassing they're
gonna keep using it
because it's effective.
What's a better thing than you've just
set some guy in a chair and have him
communicate all over the planet with
whatever matrix of intelligence exist
between him and whatever.
Okay.
What if it only works every now and
then but sometimes it really does work.
I think there's plenty of money in the
government to keep somebody like that on
tap but maybe not man.
I think it does work.
I've had so many moments where I'm
thinking of a friend and they call or I'll
get a weird feeling about somebody and
something bad will happen to them and I
know plenty of people who do that and
I know plenty of people who will get
around certain people and immediately not
be comfortable around them and they're
sensing something about that person.
I think animals are always tuning into
this deeper instinctual level so at some
point it just becomes I think semantics.
Some people are gonna say well
I just listen to my instincts.
Some people are going to say that their
psychic so I don't think that there is a
it's too out there to think that
there's some people who have especially
developed instincts where they're really
good at tuning in to watch Sheldrake
call the more for genetic field.
I think that's possible
that you could do that.
The problem is well if you if it is
possible then how come it can't be or
reproduced in laboratory settings.
And a lot of people say that immediately
discounts it but man I I can't imagine
meeting someone who's never had that
moment where you think about someone and
suddenly they call someone that
you haven't talked to in years.
You know that that has happened now.
To play devil's advocate again Sam Harris
says that all that is is coincidental
and that we think about people all the
time and they don't call but occasionally
you think about people and they do call
and then it really is just dumb luck.
But we make it out to be
this big important moment
and we sort of discredit all
the other times where it failed.
But he's like really super logical when
it comes to stuff like that to the point
where I almost have to step back like
he said that statistically no one really
ever gets a hot hand in basketball where
they can't miss it just seems like they
do.
But if you count up statistically like
there's never a zone for where there's an
unusual amount of activity over a
course of an hour it's like these little
bursts where things are really good and
then they go away but it all balances
itself out in the end.
And I've found it found that very
fascinating cause I've always felt like
someone getting in the zone whether it's
in golf or in pool or in basketball or
anything.
I always thought that was a real thing
and some people I've seen pool players do
it when you get into a place
where you just can't miss.
And you know you just find that zone and
you're significantly better than when
you're not in that zone right.
So I've always felt that
it was a real thing.
So Sam Harris is a tricky guy when it
comes to his ideas on these things.
Well who knows man.
Maybe he hasn't experienced it himself
but maybe he has and he's analyzed it
more objectively than you and I am.
That's a possibility too.
I had a dream once where in the dream
this girl that I was engaged to be married
came up to me and said hey I'm pregnant
and in the dream I was bummed out.
I'm like Oh great.
Pregnant and then the next day I woke up
and an hour after I woke up she called
to tell me that she's getting married now.
Wow.
What is that.
Well I know that that happened to me and
I know that every night I don't dream
about my ex fiancee being pregnant.
That's not a recurring dream if
it were I would be in therapy.
Is she getting married
because she's pregnant.
No.
But.
OK well then that doesn't see that's
where I would step in as a skeptic.
Not necessarily.
I'm not really a skeptic but if I was I
would say because I kind of am sometimes
I would say you probably think about her
all the time I think about my exes all
the time.
It's like a normal part of life.
Yeah.
I don't you're you you were engaged.
Sure.
And I've vivid dreams I understand that.
But you were engaged to her.
That's a very strong connection
with someone it's very
likely that you bring her
up in your mind on occasion.
I have your scenario on my stomach.
Your scenario is different than her
scenario your scenario is she was pregnant
her scenario the reality was
that she was getting married.
Well you just happen to be thinking about
her and she just happened to call you
and tell you that she's getting married
and you have made this grandiose
connection between a dream.
Well let me play the real devil's advocate
because as many Christians know the
devil is the advocate of psychics the
psychics say that what actually happens is
that your mind is kind of like scanning
and it doesn't always accurately
interpret the event.
So pregnancy and marriage that go hand
in hand and then she did end up having
children.
So the the point what makes it special
and by the way I don't I know what Sam
Harris is talking about.
They've done studies about the idea that
there's perpetually as just a vortex of
variables spinning through your mind that
consist of all the people you know and
all the things that could happen and those
things are mostly in the subconscious
but when something in the external
universe happens that resonates with
something in the subconscious that creates
the sense of synchronicity that you
say is real.
Yeah man I know that I don't always
dream about it I know the dream was very
vivid I know it was like really soon
after waking up to the point where when I
got off the phone I
was like What the fuck.
That is really weird.
So well it is like it's not outside of
the realm of possibility but all I ever
say in these situations is I try even
though I am a natural dork and my natural
inclination is to believe in psychics.
My natural inclination is to believe
in Bigfoot and aliens and UFOs and
everything.
But I also think that there's a benefit
in considering the completely numerical
scientific approach you know in looking
at how a guy like Sam Harris would look
out and go you know what you have to
address that too why wouldn't you address
that.
You know we don't want to address that
because we don't want to miss out on some
of the magic that is the world right
and we'd like to think that in in being
able to tell when things are about to
happen to you that somehow maybe that
offers you some veil of protection
that other people don't enjoy.
You know and sometime with its shit is
going to happen I'm not going to know not
to get on that plane.
You know and we would like to think that
we would like to think that I know many
people miss planes and then the plane
crashes and they swear they knew they
shouldn't get on that plane.
I mean there's probably a lot of that too.
I would if that happened I maybe I hadn't
thought it I'd say I was going to get
on the plane maybe maybe we'd become a
part of your consciousness maybe whether
you like it or not just enter in there.
Well yeah you know I like what Terence
McKenna said about people you know
ancient humans and hunting and how you
would have to develop the ability to
silently communicate with a group
of people that you're hunting with.
It would make it it would make you very
effective if as a hunter especially if
you're hunting in group situations
where you had to stalk something.
Yes.
So in that way I could see how there
might be a part of our brain that you can
develop to be acutely tuned in to what
the people around you are thinking about
doing.
I think all sports
teams are based on that.
I think that I'm sure that people who
fight or you get in there really serious
situations will tell you that they can
really tune in to every sound you hear
that when someone's in a situation where
they have to fight or they're in a life
or death situation you always hear this.
Suddenly everything becomes very loud
they can hear everything see everything.
So I think it makes sense that there is
a deeper part of the human mind that is
more aware than the conscious
part of the mind that makes sense.
I don't I don't.
I don't know if that's what psychics
say that they're using but I think that
that does exist in the human mind.
It's also possible.
I think that there is like it's almost
like a waterfall that we sort of can poke
our heads through and then pull it back
and then we can't tune in all the time.
It's very ethereal it's very slippery.
Yeah and you get it or you don't get it
and maybe some people get it better than
than we do.
But one of the things that I have to
respectfully acknowledge is that Ed dames
who has done this for so
long trains people and it
was pretty clear to me that I
needed to learn it in order to really
understand it and I didn't learn it and I
certainly didn't learn it from him.
I mean Paul taught it to me very quickly
but it was really just for the show.
You know if we had spent a bunch of time
together like over several weeks and I
really like tried to do it as if I was
a prospect for one of their programs
maybe I could learn what the hell he
was talking about maybe it's just my
silliness.
Maybe there was a breakthrough to be
had that I didn't recognize it's super
possible that that's the case.
But you know there's all
there's part of you for sure.
That's always gonna be skeptical
until it's right and front of you.
Right.
And if you've experienced
it then you have it.
You can be skeptical about the experience
but you have to acknowledge the
experience.
Yeah.
No.
And then I went to the Rhine Institute.
Okay.
And this is really interesting.
That's the.
They're the place for the Scientific
Study of the paranormal center.
And I had a great time there.
Who is the guy that ran the Ryan center.
John Cruyff.
John Carruth is the guy who ran the Ryan
center and was kind enough to take us
through and show.
I sucked it over everything I tried to
be psychic with the numbers like can
picking which button to press.
I try to be psychic with picking winners
but in the process I screwed that up.
And but one thing I did do is they had
this this room where it's totally dark
and they have this meter that measures
photons and apparently you can create
some sort of light from your body some
sort of set so some sort of photon
release that can be measured and the
highest that anybody ever did it was this
guy IRL and this guy IRL was like if he
was a character in a Will Ferrell movie
like he would be like the perfect
cohort he'd be like Will Ferrell's crazy
partner who also happens to be psychic.
Yeah and he was trying
to move me with his mind.
Ed what did I say his name was Will Earl.
He seems like it should be at Earl.
HIS NAME WAS ED Yeah.
Ed had gotten to one million on this thing
and Ed also could make you weave back
and forth.
He could he could like direct you with
his body and force force your body
backward and forward.
Or so he said he tried to do it.
I didn't move at all.
I don't know what he's
talking about but I try.
I let him try it but he's gotten
to a million on this photon thing.
I got to four hundred thousand which
they were very shocked by but I had a
battery pack on my head.
I had a microphone and when I was doing
it I was stretching so mean the battery
pack we had like tape over the
light and everything like that.
But the bottom line is there's like a
piece of electronics in the room sure.
We did it again and I got even though I
got less much less than the first time I
basically did the same stuff I was doing.
I was most like leaning
forward and touching my toes
like stretching and stuff.
And I was also trying to
breathe really hard as I was.
But then I thought about us
like how is that psychic.
What am I doing even if I can glow you
know like in a way that a human being
couldn't even perceive if you could
like hold your breath to the point we
fucking glow or get tense up and
scream to the point where you G.I.
until a spark comes out of your dick.
I don't know I don't know if that's
possible but either way it's not psychic.
I mean there was nothing I did that gave
me any inclination whatsoever that have
any psychic ability but I registered
very highly on this one silly test.
Yeah while I was running a battery pack.
Yeah.
You know it's to be the battery.
I mean I think who knows man.
I don't know call them up the next day
because he seem like an honest guy and
you know he was really excited about the
results I said you know what I think we
screwed up.
Well I think we should have done
one without the battery pack.
We did it twice to see if
we could replicate it you
know but this thing is still
on me and even though it's behind me
and we're in this when it's totally dark
room I'm still wearing a battery pack
and I'm moving around and I don't know if
Ed was doing the same
things that I was doing.
So even though my score on this this
thing was was higher I might have been
moving more than he was.
That might have been why the the light
changed in the room wearing this little
battery pack so this wasn't really
scientific test but if you look at the
evolution of animals right and you think
about animals before eyeballs existed
the evolution of the eye.
You think about the gradual
evolution of the eye.
Yeah.
There would be certain animals that
were that mutation was happening to more
than other animals.
Yet those animals could talk and they
started reporting to other animals Hey man
there is stuff all around us.
There are things swimming.
I've seeing reefs right.
That's if that the other animals like
you are out of your mind there's this
darkness and movement that's all there is.
You're crazy.
So I don't think that it's an insane
idea that our senses are continuing to
expand and to evolve right.
And if you think about what they used to
be compared to what they are now we are
like gods compared to what we used to be.
You know when we are just tiny little
lemur creatures eating each other's poop
and running from snakes all
day that's a very good point.
But another point is if that is the
case and we're pretty aware of the
established state of consciousness that
exists right now without psychic ability
we're pretty sure that most of the time
almost everywhere you go there's no
psychic ability going on it's just
normal life but little peeps of it pop
through.
Yeah.
Every now and then almost like poking
through a membrane finding its way
dissolving this membrane slowly but
surely with new experiences all the time.
But the membranes gigantic because
really what we're talking about is an
evolving ability and it takes a long
ass time for a human being to evolve an
ability.
Right.
And you know some people though say
that it's not an evolving ability it's a
devolving ability than we used to be
more tuned into what was happening around
us.
But then technology took the place of
that because really I don't need to be
telepathic I can send you a text through
the air I don't need to be in a panic
but look at birds look at birds
what they can do or look at.
Dogs.
I don't think that people think that
you that we used to be able to do it
though.
Well I think the idea is and
maybe it is a romantic idea.
But the idea is that the more tuned in
you get to nature the more tuned in you
get to the movement of things on Earth
the actual the life force on Earth.
Yeah and the more you begin to hear
deeper parts of yourself when things quiet
down you can eat like you
go in that floatation tank.
Yeah.
You know and when things really quiet
down you can hear very deep parts of
yourself that normally you
don't listen to at all.
Yeah.
So I think the idea is without all
the distractions of modern life.
People were more tuned into a
deeper instinct than we have now.
I think you're completely right.
I think that it's real possible that
we're inundated by too much sensory
overload and that we're not relying on
a lot of the instincts that we had to
rely on when we were hunter gatherers.
We're all we're doing is constantly
hunting down animals and on the prowl for
your next meal and being really in touch
with the Earth without any electrical
signals around us all the time
without any Wi-Fi without any radio.
You know I like to think that that shit
doesn't have any effect on me that I'm
not affected by Wi-Fi.
And that sounds like totally kooky talk.
Like what are you talking about man.
Scared a cell phone towers dude.
Are they zapping you.
I'm not saying that but what I am
saying is there is something undeniably
different about where it
feels when there's nothing.
If you go to a place that's in the
mountains and very peaceful and you step
outside and there's no cell phone signals
you don't I mean I guess you could
probably tune into the radio
up there but it is not much.
Yes it's fucking quiet as shit to you're
not getting any noise pollution not
getting city not.
It's a different feeling.
Now if that was life all the time
and without even the distractions the
electronic distractions that that world
sort of forces on you there's still some
who still you still have a TV still have.
If you were just in the woods all the
time it's a totally different feeling.
Yeah and if you're in the woods now
with a tracker who knows how to track
animals and they just start tracking
animals it would seem like they're magical
probably in some of the
things that they could do.
Yeah it's amazing so yeah man I think
that that there is a difference.
I just saw this awesome visual depiction
of why five you seen that it's a
picture of what Wi-Fi would look like if
if if we could see it in the air and we
look like it looks just like an ocean
like this rolling ocean of information
that we're all swimming
around in right now.
That's so crazy.
It's crazy.
How long is it going to be before
people forget about being psychic.
How long's it gonna be before you have
some sort of Verizon chip in your head
that allows you to tune into the Internet.
Not long it doesn't seem like
it's gonna be long right.
Not long ago within one hundred years.
That's gonna be reality
I think within ten years.
Really.
Yes.
Like an operation I don't know about
an operation I think within 10 years
they'll figure out a way to do it without
an operation that's going to be so
strange.
And then it will be a world of psychics
and then being psychic won't seem
strange at all because everyone will have
the ability to tune in immediately to
all information on and available to
anyone on earth or that's on the Internet
and you know some people
going to complain about that.
Again I go through.
It everyone's thinking hell for lives.
Did you hear about the cyborg that
just got beaten up in France a cyborg.
Yeah a guy's got.
There's a guy who one of
the first ocular implants.
It's like connected to his bones it's
a video camera that films things and he
was in a McDonald's in Paris and he goes
in there the owner of the McDonald's
sees him tells him to take off his google
glass he throws Google glasses and I
can't I can't take it off.
He brings medical papers with him to
show people that it's an implant right.
But they didn't care and they you know
they tried to rip it off his face but
it's connected to his bones.
Oh my God.
So the thing is got now
the thing is got in it.
This if it starts malfunctioning it
starts taking pictures of what's happening
when it malfunctions so he's got images
of these French dudes who tried to rip
his face off.
So what happened to the he's filing
charges with the police but they don't
they're not.
I mean it's like it's so weird.
The cops are like look we don't
know how to handle cyborg crime.
Yeah.
Why would they say this is
gonna be an emergent form of.
This is gonna be a new kind of hate
crime which is people beating up cyborgs.
I think that's probably
going to be the case.
I think especially if the limbs possessed
superpowers like if you start getting
into like some six million dollar man
realm where you decide to get your legs
chopped off and put these super bionic
legs on you just jumping over buildings
and shirt and you know some
guys might kick your ass.
The MillerCoors is crazy.
Good luck.
I know you have your cyborg legs.
They'll be really hard but if they hit
you in the head you probably saw a human
head you know sucker punch
you Ryan see it coming.
And then when you're out it's fuck you up.
Well this is like another problem.
This is a very off topic but this is
another problem that's emerging is that
right now the disparity in wealth is
indicated through people's possessions
their cars and their
homes and their bling.
But in the future this disparity will be
reflected in their physical appearance
so poor people who can't afford cyborg
legs or cyborg arms or implants that
allow them to tune into the Internet
they're going to have this incredible
disadvantage compared to people
who can afford the implants.
You know and that's that's a real problem
and you're really seeing evolution
there because those people
who can't afford it are
going to gradually slowly die
out.
Yeah I wonder man I really wonder if
what these what we're seeing with these
people that possess this sort of psychic
energy that tune into this psychic
Genji if everyone can do it we're just
scared of even knowing that we can do it
so we don't look into it.
I mean why haven't I looked into it.
Why haven't I picked up a book on you
know on psychic skills like there's books
on it supposedly teach you how
to cultivate your psychic skills.
I haven't given them an honest try.
I haven't like sat down with them
and been been completely objective.
So if I was making any judgment that
psychic energy wasn't real I would be I
would be kind of a dick
because it's not fair.
I really haven't tried.
I don't possess it but I haven't tried I
haven't tried to cultivate it I haven't
done any of the work these guys
had dames and and and Paul Smith.
They they have done their work
and they say they can do it.
So I have to take their word for it
but I think that I would like to see
something that really stands out for me.
I mean they had some good
stories about stuff that works.
I would like to see something really
stands out for me because the most
impressive display of psychic ability
I've ever seen in my life was self
admittedly fake a better check that was
the best display of psychic ability I
have ever seen in my life.
I do not know how he did it but I saw
him make forks bend without barely
touching them.
I saw him make them twist up in a circle
as he was guiding them his search that
as soon as I got down to find out how
to do that and would they say well what
you do is you take a I mean
there's a step by step guide to it.
Know it's possible.
Oh yeah.
You take the you take aluminum forks.
Right exactly like what he had.
And I mean this is according to the
YouTube thing I didn't spend a lot of time
with it because you have to bend but
you bend them right so you bend them and
they heat up.
So before you do your show you
spend some time on these forks.
They get there by bending them they heat
up they're looser and then that makes
them more bendable.
And I imagine that's it.
Ben this is not a if you google search
a lot of what he did there is it shows
how to do it on the really.
Yeah.
Boy I would like to see that because I
guess it's very possible I didn't really
completely thoroughly examine those force
but I did click them together and they
were metal.
Clink clink and I picked them up I looked
at them there were real forks whether
or not that was the fourth that actually
made it into his hand when he did that.
I don't I mean there's guys that are
really good with sleight of hand.
Yeah.
You know they're really good with it.
So that's possible but what's important
is that he says it's bullshit all right.
He told us that it's all tricks.
He said I'm not psychic I have no psychic
energy I can't tell you how I did this
because then I would reveal my
sources but I'm not psychic.
I believe him.
I mean I don't have any
reason to not believe him.
He seems like a very nice guy
and it was very entertaining.
He's very very talented like I felt like
we really got a treat because we got
like a very small intimate
show with a master magician.
Yeah.
I mean he really is a master.
So it was really entertaining.
And then the fact that on top of that
he was telling us that it was all just
tricks.
I found that to be like
really fascinating.
Oh yeah.
He's like an uber skeptic.
Yeah.
And he's showing how it's so easy to
manipulate people and he's showing how
you've got to be very careful when you
get around somebody who tells you that
they can talk to dead people they can
talk to invisible people because you get
all you get a lot of
trouble with those folks.
Well he fooled scientists for four years.
Yeah.
They thought he had real psychic
abilities for four years he fooled them.
Yeah it's amazing.
He made me much more skeptical but I'm.
But he still didn't.
You can't remove from me like experiences
I've had where it's like I don't know
what that is but it's such an incredible
coincidence that it seems beyond
coincidence.
I don't think he was
trying to remove that.
I think what he was trying to do
is it's show that you could B.S.
people yes you can.
And that's what he did.
He B.S.
people.
He's.
I don't think he's saying that you can't
have these unique moments where where
something becomes apparent to you.
I think what he was trying to do was
just show you that you can be tricked.
Yes.
And he was really good.
I mean really good at it.
Amazing at it.
We put coins over his eyeballs duct taped
his face and he read the serial number
on a bill that was in my pocket.
I have no idea how he did that
he wasn't even looking at it.
He was looking over there.
Yeah.
That was crazy man.
It was crazy a lot of
what he did was crazy.
First of all he's 50 OK.
The idea that he could read
it from my hand this far away.
I've got it I've got it a full arm's
length away from his face that he can even
look over and read that serial number
there's little tiny print on a dollar
bill.
They're going to read that from there.
That would be really hard to do.
But with duct tape over your face or
coins over your eyeball yet and you're not
even looking at it I
don't know how he did it.
I don't know how he did
a lot of what he did.
It was amazing.
Yeah.
That girl when he picked her out of the
audience and told her her dog's name.
That girl freaked out man.
She was like ready to cry.
She got emotional you could see her face.
Her jaw was and she wasn't a plant.
No she wasn't.
You know what I didn't know though man
when I was getting all shrill of IRA
being a plant as I didn't know that
in the beginning it had people write
information down and
put it into an envelope.
Yeah but she didn't write about her dog.
Well I don't know that you know.
We know that we read her information.
She did write about her dog did read
the information and the crew did.
We had we had her information read right.
Yes she didn't write
a thing about her dog.
Well then
see she wrote the dogs.
Now women he got.
Did you read all that shit.
Yes
she wrote it and put it in her purse.
OK.
Do you know that there are pens and when
you write things down these pens they
create an exact replica of that in a
computer program and they work wirelessly.
See I didn't know that bit of information.
So my mind was just trying to decode
what he did because it would've been
impossible.
Then it's like oh well we don't know
maybe she used her own pen which in case
Look man she said he named initials and
you would get that from someone writing
their name on a thing right.
Maybe he had a camera that
was watching all of them.
Well I guess the point is like we're
trying to figure out the specifics of what
he did but it's no question that what
he did was tragic and it was a trick
because that's what he said.
He even had a camera behind me with a
zoom lens and that's how he could read
that.
That's also he could
react on the audience.
I mean who the hell knows.
Yeah there's no way to how far in
advance did he know where we were going.
How long in advance did he know.
No idea
the location.
No idea how I got there.
Did he knew or know about it
beforehand though before the call.
Possibly.
I don't think it's
we're we're we're trying to do here folks
listening to this is trying to figure
out how the hell that guy did what
he did what he did was masterful.
I mean everything about it even if it was
tricks whatever it was it was amazing.
But having him say that it was tricks
and it was so good it makes you really
call into question all the other
psychic ability that people claim.
Well another thing that it does is it
shines a light on how monstrous some
people are because imagine being such a
sociopath that you use tricks like that
to get around people to show them that
you have powers and then you charge them
money to let them communicate with their
dead relatives your people who do that
for a living.
They are the most vile monstrous people
on earth because they seek out the most
gullible humans who are desperate and
morning and full of grief and guilt and
then they do a couple banter check tricks.
They get them convinced that they are
magical and then they're like Yeah for a
thousand bucks or for a donation I'll
let you say hello to your mom again.
Yeah.
He was very adamant about
his his hate for that.
That type of price that minute bit of
practice and what he does he calls himself
a mentalist and he's an entertainer
and he's also a debunker.
He likes to debunk stuff you tell
people that what he's doing is a trick.
Yeah.
Just so you know he's so good at it
and he's telling you it's a trick.
So be careful because other people were
probably tricking you too but they're
not going to be as ethical as he is.
All right.
He's a really cool guy man.
That was a real privilege
it having him on the show.
But it is fun to imagine that he's just
an evil Talib he's just an awesome real
psychic and that's how he makes a
living by pretending he's not he's not.
He just goes there because he knows
that if he tells people that being a
telepath is possible then everyone will
have telepathic abilities and he'll he
won't you won't be special anymore.
I wonder if he used his own pen if he
made them write their stuff down with his
pen.
That would explain a lot.
We don't.
I do know that they can do that now.
They have these special pens his
computer pens and they dictate.
Well we don't know.
We got to get your pen back.
I mean I know you don't know
you can do it wirelessly.
No but if you have like a I'm saying
you want to get your magic wireless pen
back.
You don't want it true sir but I.
But I think that they gave their pen
back anyway and people don't steal pens
when you fill out a rhyme especially if
you say can I have my pen back please.
Like if the magic Pentagon to ask Can I
have that blinking pen back that I gave
the lower the numbers says
only megabytes are left.
Yeah.
I don't know what these tricks were
but the important thing is that he says
there were tricks.
Yes.
And they were amazing.
Yeah but just because someone can emulate
something doesn't mean that it's not
real.
But it made going to the Rhine Research
Center feel so silly you know like me
standing in front of these things trying
to figure out which one's gonna go off
next and totally getting nothing right.
Like thinking like maybe
I've got this power.
And then this guy comes along that
shows you like the craziest psychic shit
you've ever seen in your life.
And then just goes oh by
the way it's all lies.
Yeah it's true man.
I mean there's a you can do a lot.
You could do a lot like think of Rasputin
think of like grass butin this dirty
filthy guy who just comes
into Russia says that he's a.
Psychic or a mystic and the next thing
you know he's basically running Russia by
manipulating the leaders because he's
convinced them that he has these powers.
I mean you can go far if you can
convince people even something out about
Rasputin his giant cock his giant cock
his cock that was so giant that cut it
off and bottled it.
They saved it forever.
You know a jar of formaldehyde.
And people go to a museum
in Russia and look at it.
Yeah.
That's a Vegas caucus.
I've seen that just like
eleven inches flaccid.
Yeah.
It's a giant hog.
It's a terrible thing to
terrible evil looking dick.
Yeah it is.
Imagine going into a woman that you
once loved just plunging into her.
I think that when the apocalypse happens
it's going to wake up and break out of
that jar.
It's going to come out.
Is he taking his digs into sprout
legs in the middle of the night.
No.
Remember that scene in aliens.
The second one.
Where.
What's his face.
Mad About You kept
the chick in the in the lab tried to
get her contaminated with one of those
little face huggers.
It would be like it'd
be like the face hugger.
It's going to grow some legs and Kravitz
way around the laboratory till it
shoves its giant pickled
cock in your mouth.
Giant giant pickled wizard.
Hundreds of years of formaldehyde soaked
in this terrible green pulsating zombie
Dick with crab legs and antique jizz
remnants pile and that's where it starts.
They open up the vault to try to rescue
and you know it's a fucking swarm like a
beehive of bugs flying through the air
that are all miniature little little
giant flying crab cocks and they just
it just spreads it spreads like like a
like a virus aerial.
That would be the funniest apocalypse.
They're looking at it on a slide for
the first time and it's a little tiny.
Evil cocks flapping their wings like
what the fuck are we looking at.
They have to look at it like 100 x
hundred times the size just to get it.
Or do we see two giant pickled
cocks with wings next to my thigh.
Little tiny.
Yeah that's right.
The Sharknado man right.
Yeah.
That's.
I think that it's a that's a
terrifying aspect of Rasputin.
Also the fact that they shot him several
times and they kept Yeah poisoned them
they lost his voice and shot him.
I think due to the Dick that big as a
special man you probably have a lot of
special tolerances.
You know it's a rigid human being.
If you got a big giant cock like that.
It's like the universe is like trying
really hard to get you to breed you know
like.
Right.
We all know that like penis size no
matter what anybody says it's means
something.
If it didn't mean anything it wouldn't
bother if you dig a little it means
something.
OK.
And you probably don't need
a gigantic humongous one.
But if you have one you got that.
That's that's a big thing with people.
So when a guy like Rasputin comes
along and he has a giant cock and he's
charismatic with a big giant cock.
Yeah.
It's it's a perfect storm of evil scary
giant horse cock can communicate with
the dead.
That's all you need to take over Russia.
It is a real problem with
people that were gullible.
You know that we want a balloon boy
silly things in over the course of this
show.
One of the things that I've found is
how many people get upset at you if you
don't believe the things
that they believe.
Yeah well you feel embarrassed.
I mean yeah part of it
is you feel embarrassed.
You want to defend it because you can't
you know that if you're experiencing
some strange thing that some part
of you is going to be skeptical.
And when you decide to believe in the
strange thing then you become very
defensive.
It's embarrassing.
And that's that I think
that's why sometimes you
feel a little bit of sympathy
for some of these people but yes they've
invested their lives into ideas that
they haven't fully investigated
or explored in a real way.
Right.
It's really sad when you know knocking
the legs out from under the table upon
which rests a person's entire paradigm.
That's a sad thing to see happen you're
watching someone fight against that with
all their might.
Yeah.
And we're seeing that every week.
Yeah yeah.
Every week we're seeing some some
person who believes something.
And I think somewhere along the line the
show is becoming more about psychology
than it is even about these ideas.
Oh yeah man.
And it's one thing it's taught me is is
that we can't let people who believe in
invisible unprovable things
have any kind of power.
That's what it's showing me like.
Now a lot of these people
you meet them there.
They don't have a church a congregation.
They haven't started a religion but you
can see how someone like that if they
had power they would be incredibly
dangerous if you're around somebody.
Yeah.
Well I think that people having
power in that sense like the.
Presidential power or king type power
is probably going to be a thing of the
past one day.
I think ultimately we're gonna realize
that anybody that gets to control people
it's probably a bad idea.
It should all be like some sort of a group
minded thing because if it's not then
you get led into wars and you get led
into crazy situations bank takeovers and
bailouts and stuff.
I just saw a video on a Christian show
which is a speech of Ronald Reagan when
he's president talking about
how he believes that the
end of the world is going
to happen in Israel based
on biblical prophecy.
This is a president who controls nuclear
weapons and he's free freely saying
this is what I believe it's better
prophesies done in the old testament.
It's like no no your president you can't
believe that you're not supposed to
believe that yes it's too weak an
idea it's too weak an idea too.
And if you exhibit this week idea it
should disqualify you from controlling
anything because it says
it's a crazy persons thought.
So we have to re-evaluate.
Oh did we just let a charismatic
crazy person run things.
Or did we really pick a wise leader
right to the point when the point is a
leader can't really be a leader.
You need a bunch of people working with
you need a hole and everyone says that.
But there's still a president.
It should there shouldn't be one.
There shouldn't be.
There's no fucking way one person
should be running anything.
So yeah.
One person who believes crazy
shit shouldn't be running
anything you know well
shouldn't be running anything anybody.
No one should be running
a goddamn country right.
No one it should be the entire
country gets to vote on shit.
Yes.
You know what I think you can go a
totally different sense of who people are
based on that.
Like read it.
Yeah.
Run the country with a rabbit.
Or Yeah I've be true to my or Twitter.
Imagine if you could vote on Twitter.
Yeah I would be amazed.
It would be incredible.
It would be amazing but also
probably pretty easy to hack.
Maybe but why can we do
our banking online then.
Right.
Good point.
You tell me you trust it with money
you don't trust it with votes.
That's ridiculous.
Right sounds like you
want to manipulate votes.
They can do it.
They can do pretty much everything online
with banking and you're dealing with
millions and billions of dollars every
day going back and forth including the
stock market.
Yeah so you're fine with
all that but we can't vote.
Voting is too complicated.
That's the.
One man one vote.
What are you trying to say.
The whole system would have a
bunch of hackers getting control.
You want a bunch of guys
with Guy Fawkes masks.
One in this fucking country right.
They can't give it back to the people
and they know that's what that would be.
They do it.
They can't do it.
You can never do it.
It'll never.
You'll never be able to vote.
Well I think you eventually will because
I think the people that are in the
position to control things will eventually
get phased out let new people come
in.
I just think it's inevitable because
the generations that are coming up it's
going to be way harder to be as corrupt
as the generations that are in power
that are just used to abusing it
and having that kind of control.
You wouldn't want that.
Like if you could have the
level of control of like a
Julius Caesar I think it's
dangerous.
Things change.
Fuck no.
I would if it was like me or Hitler.
I'd say yeah.
You know I'm saying.
But it's never that and I think it's
really what it should be is we should all
have ideas that we share and we should
all have maybe things that we agree on or
disagree on or things that we
can debate public discourse.
But ultimately it should be a vote should
be 300 million people X amount of them
are over 18 whatever the age do we decide
is it really should be probably 21.
Yeah.
And then from there on they
get to make the choice.
Yeah but what if what if for example
this voting happens in a country where
people believe in like Sharia law and
believe that women should be covered in
burqas and that you know sort of that
you cut off someone's hand who steals.
What if there's
red or white with a machine.
Really.
Would they convict her of Oh my God.
That's scary.
Right.
Read her mind.
It was admissible admissible in court
that she actually had prior knowledge of
this crime.
That's incredible
experience and knowledge.
That's incredible.
Not admissible not admissible in the
U.S. Court while tell the story if people
listen to this I didn't hear what
they just said is that there.
There is a woman in India
that was convicted with this
machine called an F M r.
I.
What does it stand for.
Functional MRI Magnetic Resonance imagery
is what MRI stands for and that she
was convicted for murder because they
knew that she had some sort of a memory of
the crime and they were able
to read her mind find that wow.
Holy shit that's incredible.
That's cool.
I think that eventually we're going to
have a hard drive on our brain and I
think we're gonna be able to record
life in a way that looks exactly as if
you're live in it.
And I think you'll be able to
watch it and experience it.
I think first of all probably visual.
But then as people the technology gets
better and better and people get more
advanced.
We'll figure out a way to
experience everything too.
Would be like black and white TV.
They started out it was just a
black and white television right.
Then also there was color HD stereo
stereo sound worth those winds whistling
behind human TV today are incredible.
Yeah but they start out as big stupid
wooden box with this dumb little tube in
the middle of it that look like shit.
It was rounded like a fishbowl.
I think that first they're
gonna start out with video.
It's gonna be you in the video and have
some sort of an audio and you got to be
a play it back.
Google Glass.
Something along those lines but it'll
be all the time and you'll be able to
access it.
You'll have a giant like 18 trillion
terabyte hard drive in your head.
Yeah and you'll be able to
access your entire life.
So we're gonna have to people are going
to be able to read your minds by just
taking it out.
Yeah and like we'll see what Duncan was
doing up beaten off the tranny porn.
Where are you.
Duncan yelling ball gags and tranny porn.
Sure they'll be able to
find out what you saw.
No way.
There was nothing wrong with that man.
And the more we realize the quicker we
realize there's nothing wrong with that
the happier Robbie but the.
The.
The point is that they're going to
be it was gonna be a moot point.
I think everyone's going to be psychic.
Yes exactly.
I mean yeah for sure people if you look
at how we already are psychic and not
connected to our heads yet more certainly
way more psychic today than people
were that were living
in like you know 15 20.
Yes.
You know what we can do now is
call it what it call what you will.
The connection is always on and it's
much more powerful and we can do things
incredible like talk to people that are
on the other side of the world in real
time.
I mean what is it.
I am pregnant misquoted but didn't
Asimov say technology that is an
and a technology.
I'm going to butcher this quote but it's
nothing like a technology an advanced
enough technology would be
indistinguishable from magic.
Yes that's exactly the quote.
So that's so that's the idea which is
that if you were to go back and tell
people yes we use wireless signals
to show us where we're going.
We use wireless signals to communicate
with people on the other side of the
planet.
We use wireless signals to control cars.
We use wireless signals to do everything.
People be like What are you talking
about how is that even possible.
But now it's real.
And so I'm sure that in the future once
technology becomes more part of us than
we all become cyborgs then in that way
the notion of being able to mentally
merge with a person
won't seem insane at all.
In fact you will be able to merge
with the consciousness of the planet.
There'll be some kind of emotional
Internet where you can empathic we
technologically merge with all human
beings and experience the way the entire
planet feels.
I think you're absolutely right.
I think that we're starting to feel the
beginnings of this with the Internet
that we're experiencing today.
I think the Internet is joining
people today in a way that we've never
experienced before.
And it's just begun.
And I think the next step is probably
going to be lot more immersive.
Yes.
And that next step might deal with real
time video and audio from person to
person you might be able
to access people's actual
experiences as they're taking
place.
Sure and then there's going to be
designer augmented realities where you can
have you can download upgrades just a
normal reality like make your reds redder
yeah make the colors deeper let's turn
it turn let's let's enhance smells and
they'll be like well let's change smells
all together this turns the smell of
far into roses.
So from now on you're not
going to smell any bad things.
And that's going to be
what starts happening as we
begin to enhance our reality
technologically which I've
heard in Google Glass.
It's already happening like the one
thing that they're desperately trying to
keep out of Google Glass
is facial recognition.
But someone's already hacked it.
So it does that because the last thing
you want is for a stranger to be able to
walk up to you with Google Glass scan
your face go do a google image search and
come up with like Oh hey
Ted do you remember me.
Really.
That's a problem as you like wait do I
really know you or are you just using the
Internet.
So they don't want that to happen.
But the thing about it is
they're already going to hack it.
That happens and then you can
have like a yelp for people.
You know what I mean so that when you're
doing facial scans for people you could
see hanging above them douchebag
rapist or pedophile or whatever.
So people are going to be cursed with
this cloud that whatever is about them in
the cloud will be around them and you
can you could change that you can upgrade
it if you want.
You can make it so that assholes always
have flies swarming around them you know
to avoid them.
That's a great idea.
Yeah.
If technology really can do that and we
start judging each other based on our
experiences.
But you're gonna have like you're gonna
have to look at a guy's record to like.
OK.
Who gave you one star.
Oh look at this guy he's an asshole.
Sure.
You could tell.
You know we already can't do that
like you just takes a second.
Yeah I can already get your name and go
on your Facebook account and within 10
seconds figure out if you're a douchebag.
Yeah.
I mean how many times you
gonna to someone's Twitter
and you go Oh I know what's
going on in your head.
Yeah.
Quick right away.
That's sort of psycho in a way.
Yeah.
I mean it's communicative and essentially
the idea of psychic is it cuts out all
the middlemen and you get
right to the information.
Yeah yeah yeah.
It's a it's a form of technologically
enhanced connectivity that's never existed
as far as we know on this planet until
today and it's only going to get more and
more intense and everyone's you know
this is part of the thing where ever it's
like oh god the NSA they're watching
everything I do there's no more privacy
it's like oh you have no idea.
You're so lucky right now if you exist
right now this is the last era of
privacy.
It's already there's hardly any privacy
if you do something dumb enough on a
city bus the entire planet will
see if you if you murder someone.
It's so much more difficult to get
away with it today than it's ever been
before.
Yeah but you can't commit a crime you
commit a crime if you just do something
embarrassing if you like if you try to
take a burning tequila shot and set your
face on fire within 30 minutes the entire
planet might be looking at that event.
So privacy is already going
the way of the dinosaur.
But in 15 years you will
not be able to go outside.
Do you think to be out for it.
Do you think that's going to
cause a convergence though
a real convergence where
people have real empathy for other people
because they're experiencing they're
paying their feelings all the time.
I think that if anything positive can
come out of this connection that human
beings are experiencing it's going to
be that are going to realize somewhere
along the line that we're going to all
be a lot better off if everybody's happy
and there must be a way if you can get
two people to be happy or for people to
be happy.
Why can't you get four million.
What is missing.
Well at what point in time does it become.
Does everybody lose value.
Is it 4000 is it forty
thousand four hundred thousand.
There's a number where people stop giving
a shit about certain people they read
about the newspaper.
If there's only four of you one
of you dies everybody gets sad.
Yeah but if this four million of you
like we lost another one today hey this
fucking four million people
don't worry about it.
Yeah right.
Man Well I think that's one part of it.
I think the other part of it is there's
going to just be people even more
addicted and negativity and like the NAB
think so yeah I think the Nancy Grace
show is gonna be really hard to watch
because you'll be able to emotionally tune
into it and guarantee
Nancy Grace if you like.
Here's the way it feels to be an eight
year old getting strangled to death.
People want to experience
those dark things too.
But I think ultimately it's the ultimate
device of peace because when let's say
the president of Iran sits down with
the president of Israel and they
telepathically merge minds so that one
can experience the totality of the other
person's life and what they whatever
their religion is and whatever their ideas
are if those things merge thinking
like oh shit we're exactly the same.
We really are the same.
That's that's the problem.
Yeah yeah the problem is if you live
their life you would have a very similar
way of looking at the world as they do
and they lived yours they would probably
have all your experiences all your hopes
and dreams and loves and conquests and
failures all that shit together makes you.
And unless someone is you.
It's hard it's hard for
them to understand you.
But when we all can see each
other it's gonna get real weird.
Man it's hard for you to understand you
much less somebody else but you still
you know where else it's going to ruin
it's going to ruin the meat industry
because the first thing PETA is gonna do
is slap one of these brainwave devices
on a cow that's about to get slaughtered.
Send that up on the Internet be
like Go ahead eat a cheeseburger.
But first experienced this insane terror
that that meat felt right before it got
murder.
I think you're right it's
going to be a weird world.
I think there's gonna be a lot of weird
things we're gonna be able to experience
a lot of weird ways and we're gonna be
able to be in touch with each other.
And also getting hacked our minds are
gonna be able to get hacked and that's
another scary thing in the way that
sometimes you wake up and someone will be
and you'll have like six emails from your
friends being like hey asshole you got
fished.
I don't want to buy a purse.
Please stop trying to sell
me purses in the same way.
You might wake up in like your brain has
been hacked and implanted all over your
brain as the desire to go
eat a cheeseburger to like
go on a certain website.
That's another scary thing.
Yeah.
Are we go with this episode.
We just have a few little bits to hear.
What do you have to greatest
you haven't been the right.
Right.
But I said it earlier I
talked about the run as to
what you mean what you said is great.
Kind of do it as if you
haven't been there yet.
Okay.
So I'm headed to this place called the
Rhine Research Center and it's the gold
standard for the scientific
study of the paranormal.
Yeah I've heard of them they make the
cards they've been studying the paranormal
since the 1930s.
So I'm going to go there and
see what they can show me.
What kind of scientific proof they could
demonstrate that apparently they can
show you all the different ways that they
can measure psychic ability and we're
gonna we're gonna try a few out.
Yeah man they're the ones who invented
those psychic cards at those squiggly
lines in the square in the circle.
They're the ones that
came up with that test.
Yeah.
Well apparently they say some
people have innate abilities.
Some people don't.
Some people you can you can sort
of cultivate their their abilities.
Some people can't.
Sure I believe it.
We'll see.
I'm open minded.
I'll go check it out.
Yeah.
They're very respected.
Good luck.
So.
Anyone looking to get more information
on any of these subjects we're talking
about.
Go to sci fi dot com there's like
clips and videos go check that out.
Spell it because they spell it.
Yeah s y f y dot com people
look was you stupid Sean.
There's not even science fiction.
You're right but it's as s y f y dot
com they got you on a technicality.
So yeah it's not the sci fi channel
anymore like as an only science fiction.
But it's still pronounced sci fi and
you have a right to be upset at me.
I understand that if I wasn't me and I
was watching this and I wanted to see
Battlestar Galactica I'd be like
was the fear factor do Sean right.
I'm looking to watch some Battlestar
Galactica some science fiction right but
it's not just science fiction.
Like you know that one channel that sticks
to their name while learning channel
that's all about learning as.
If you have now.
So I like people wrestling pigs.
What do they have on now it's all
reality shows learning channel is like.
Well what do they have.
Honey honey boo boo's on
the Learning Channel horn.
What are we learning.
People are really stupid as fuck
and I'm learning I love honey.
Borders is on blurring show why hoarders.
You say hoarders I think hoarders isn't
hoarders on the arts and entertainment.
There is on arts and entertainment.
Right.
Because I'm an art or
an entertainment both.
So you know I don't know man.
I don't.
I don't know about this.
This psychic ability thing I think we
have to wrap it up now but my my take on
it is I did not feel like in doing the
show that it disproved anything to me.
It did prove to me that there's guys
like Bana check who are absolutely
masterful at doing what he did.
However he did it.
He claims that it's a
trick and he's not psychic.
I believe him.
What he did was amazing though.
So I learned that
there's people like that.
I was really blown away by
his abilities but I didn't.
It didn't take away from me
the possibility that a guy
like Ed dames can remote
view or their guy like
Paul Smith can remove you.
I couldn't do it.
I didn't see evidence of it but there's
enough there for me enough anecdotal
evidence enough stories of these guys
seeing things that turned out to be real
that I would be foolish if I dismissed
it without actually learning how to do
it.
And that was one of the important
things so I'm going to leave it at that.
I don't know whether or not psychic energy
is real but I am incredibly impressed
impressed.
Say again I don't know if psychic energy
is real or psychic abilities real but
I'm incredibly impressed at
Banamex ability to fake it
and it deems descriptions
of how it works.
So that's where I'll leave it.
Cool.
I'm in the middle on it.
I'm all over the place.
I know people out there try
to develop their abilities.
I should too.
You know I don't know what's wrong with
me why I don't want to like sit down or
read a book on it.
I really need to figure out what's
what's wrong with me that I don't want to
give it a chance.
God when I was a kid I used to
read those books all the time.
Did they work.
No.
But like I would.
I remember reading that you could sit
and like if you stare at the back of
someone's neck you could make them look
at you Savi riding in the car and just
staring at the back of my brother's neck
trying to get into turnaround it work.
I mean there's cardio shit i absolutely
tired of my shit and he would turn
around anyway to punch me.